who here has heard of gopher and who
likes gopher wow that's not a whole lot
I really did like go for a whole lot
because you know it was a protocol that
allowed me to extract information and
while the usability wasn't really that
great I wasn't distracted by a lot of
the bling that we see nowadays on the
web and probably as many of you thank
you very much for showing up probably
like many of you I'm sort of at war with
what the web has become because when I
go out there and I want to surf I want
the information I I know what I want to
get and I don't want anything other
shoved into my face but unfortunately
today's experience of the web is quite a
different one let me just for the sake
of demonstration so this is this talk is
going to be live demo I have sacrificed
a goat this morning so it should work
out unfortunately I'm a little bit
unused to the UI here the the the
resolution so you might have to bear
with me a little bit and let's load a
web site stuff code on and Zedd which is
sort of the slash dot of New Zealand
don't quote me on that and here you go
stuff is loading what you can see down
here in the network console are HTTP
requests are being sent out from my
browser to various parts of the Internet
as part of the web site loading up here
and and here is a wonderful extension
called Firefox lightbeam that attempts
to visualize what's going on so it went
really fast the network here is
blazingly fast but you can see that
every single one of these triangles that
have gathered around the circle in the
middle which is my website are actually
third parties that my browser has
reached out to in order to obtain
resources or maybe to let that party
know what I'm doing in total its 23
third-party sites and I'm a little bit
confused right now because when I did
this yesterday so
73 and so I'm thinking that I may have
left some of the settings that I'm about
to talk to you about on and so we're
being protected from trackers oh yeah
here it is tracking protection so
Firefox actually has tracking protection
built in in recent versions let me turn
that off and reload the page because I
want this to be a little bit bigger
there you go we're twenty six already
it's still loading and still loading you
can see all the requests down here we're
still loading there's a whole bunch
about to come in there you go
27 29 32 34 35 and so on and so forth
look at what's happening down here I'm
just loading a website I'm just loading
a web site okay let's be fear for a
second let me take stuff coded and zette
out of this right so this is now only
the requests that are not going to
anywhere within the stuff that coded in
that domain we're at 68 third party site
69 35 70 71 72 and 73 oh yes something
changed 75 this is amazing 76 77 the
world is finding out about me visiting
this website and I haven't even started
scrolling yet yeah I mean let's scroll
okay are you ready for this let's scroll
okay nothing's happening this is a bit
of it anti-climactic situation here I'm
not prepared for this theoretically
there's more stuff going on that's right
theoretically technology has it such
that trackers what we're visiting here a
witnessing here trackers actually have
the ability to analyze how much time I'm
spending on a given section of a website
so asked to and that is the entire
problem that I'm talking to you about
today
maximize ad revenue because at some
point in time somebody came up with the
idea that to finance the free Internet
we serve ads and then obviously someone
thought better of it and said no that's
wrong expression in English somebody
improved upon that idea and started to
serve ads that you wanted to see and
that was basically the bird
of the ad industry as we know it
nowadays
now I don't want to risk doing too much
of an HTTP 101 course here but do let me
quickly look at what one of these
requests is so that we know what we're
talking about at other conferences
there's this thing called clicking you
know people start clicking when they
really like something I'm gonna propose
that you start clicking when you really
don't like what I'm doing so that I get
an idea about when when I'm boring you
so I can move on yeah so let's look at
one of these requests here let's go to
[Music]
pub Matic comm for instance and let's
look at specifically the requests that
I'm sending out so you can see a couple
of fields in here there I'm sending I'm
telling this pub Matic dot-com website I
have no idea what they do but stuff
supposedly does that I'm surfing the web
with my mozilla 5.0 it's actually
running on a PowerPC Mac it's not the
case but we're faking a user agent here
a little bit yeah I was supposed to have
turned that off but apparently I didn't
I'm sorry about that
we're also telling it the refer where
I'm coming from
again this is they're actually not
supposed to be that website already you
just have a look what I'm doing wrong
here there's something not set correctly
okay well for all intents and purposes
the theory goes that my browser is
telling this website on the request that
is being made that I'm coming from a
different website so that actually the
websites out there can plot where I'm
coming from and where I'm going to and
UK I don't and then finally there's
another field in here called cookie and
basically I'm not going to tell you much
about cookies but basically last time I
went to that site the web server
instructed my browser to please when it
comes back to that web server send that
information presumably so they can
present a customized version but also so
they can track me so I don't
particularly like that pretty sure that
nobody out there would particularly like
that if they knew what was going on but
as we heard from Serena earlier nobody
really knows or cares or has the
possibility to really do something about
that so what I want to show you today is
a selection of Firefox add-ons most of
those work with chromium as well by the
way that I use in order to minimize the
footprint print that I leave when I surf
the web and first and foremost of those
my absolute favorite is called you
matrix now you matrix is not about the
matrix you matrix is about a table with
rows and columns and I'm going to try to
figure out how to use the very limited
screen estate that I have available to
show you what I mean there you go this
is you matrix you I it is currently
disabled but I'm trying to show you what
it can do because when you scroll down
on the UI of you matrix you can see in
the rows every single server that my
browser has reached out to and in the
columns the type of resource that is
being requested so about halfway down
the the line now yeah it's a lot going
on clearly everything of all of that is
necessary for me to just read the news
so this this may or may not be a better
way to illustrate what's going on I mean
light beam is very visual this is a
little bit more structured versus the
network console that I showed with a lot
of data that are basically swampthing
going to swap anyone looking at it but
the great thing about you matrix is that
I can actually now start interacting in
configuring my browser and telling my
browser specifically what I wanted to do
and what I don't want it to do right now
the whole thing is disabled so I'm going
to turn this on and the visuals have
changed to the point where yellow now
indicates I want resources to be loaded
from this site and blue means I do not
want this site the server to be
contacted you'll also notice that up
here in the column header CSS and image
is selected by default because clearly
we need style sheets and we also need
images always on from everywhere and
because images and CSS files are not
Google Analytics nobody's going to track
us right well I'm pretty sure you all
have heard of the 1x1 pixel images that
are being loaded there are quite a
couple of stuff on start codon and Zed
which I'm not going to bother
identifying in a network stream right
now so let's get rid of images and load
them only when I need them not by
default anyway and this is a choice that
I can make using this user interface and
also CSS files I mean it's great that I
can you know have bold and larger fonts
and even wet fonts yeah but then again
fun start Google API so calm I'm not
saying that that is a tracking resource
but if I were running a company that
whose business model was based on data I
might might use those access logs so I'm
turning it off I'm turning the default
off turning the follow on images off
that's actually now for stuff
cohdon and Zedd let me explain one other
part of this UI which is the very top
left corner you can see that I can
actually apply different rules to
different sub parts of the domain so I
can actually make rules apply to WWE or
just do stuff Doug coder than Zedd
we're just decoder than dead which is
highly useful or to everything and as a
matter of fact I kind of I personally
make the choice that by default for
everything out there I do not want CSS
and images to be loaded from any
resource out there except for the first
party because that's kind of the point
of the web I mean you know if you're
yeah you get it so I'm going to keep
that on I'm also going to allow frames
from the first party frames or otherwise
considered evil sometimes that's which
is why they're blue up here but I'm
going to allow that for the first party
so if I go back and change the view to
stuffed or coded and Zed the default of
CSS and images has now changed
none of these images and CSS further
down here are being loaded by default
except for the first party because I'm
actually prepared to give my data to
stuff otherwise I shouldn't be browsing
their website in the first place so with
that in place let's reload down here we
have the network console I'm going to
leave the filter off showing nothing
that actually goes to stuff itself in
place and I've reset over here the light
beam data I'm going to do a control
shift are and reload the stuff website
note how the network console stays empty
this means that there are currently no
requests being sent to any other website
out there except for stuff itself look
at light beam to third-party sites being
contacted
what are those oh my god stuff codon and
Zed and resources start stuff that codon
and Zed I consider that okay in the
context of this exercise and what about
the website
Hey look it's got a headline there's
text it's even got images it's almost
like I can read the news but there are
no advertisements there are no trackers
nobody else but stuff and myself find
out right now what I'm doing now at this
point in time I'd like to say that stuff
and various other journalistic agencies
out there they do their stuff common
words there they do their work for free
on the web kinda right
ads are used to pay salaries and I'm in
no position here and I certainly do not
want to advertise for there's another
problem where it's there gosh I'm so
terrible advertise for blocking ads but
it's sort of what the game has become
ads are a symptom or maybe the cause
they're definitely right in the middle
of this tracking business and if I value
my privacy and ads are but what go
against my privacy choices then I'm
sorry but I won't load them I'm sorry
stuff Dakota and Zed I load your website
I'll happily consume your news and hey
if you allowed me to for instance have a
very simple micropayments process by
which I could give you a dollar every
single time I like something I might
actually do that but I'm certainly not
going to pay with my data with my usage
patterns that you feed on - how many
were there 78 79 third-party sites who
will do with those data I don't know
what now I've actually said nobody but
myself and stuff find out about this and
this is because another extension that
I've used here is HTTPS Everywhere we've
kind of gotten to the point now where
almost everything is HTTPS anyway but
please do have that extension enabled in
your browsers anyway because it ensures
that even though there are legacy
possibilities of contacting web servers
on port 80 this extension will make sure
that that
only happens once the first time and
from then on you'll be on a secure
connection whatever secure means in that
context so I'm going to enable that it's
going to reload the website but nothing
is actually going to change over here
just to complement matrix gives me a
couple of other tools that I hope wrong
extension a couple of other tools that I
can use to further limit my footprint
and those are for bidding mixed content
that's I believe non SSL content and SSL
websites for bidding web workers if any
of you have been to Kubek on there was a
fantastic talk about service workers and
web workers those kind of processes in
your browser that can stick around for
hours after you stop visiting a web site
and actually act in your behalf within
your environment and keep sending data
back and forth so you may not want that
you can turn these off globally you can
turn them on for individual websites
very helpful spoof the referer header
somehow I already did that which
basically just means I'm not going to
tell any site where I'm coming from but
I'm just gonna pretend that I'm coming
from their site so you saw that earlier
when we went to that advertising page it
pretended to come from the advertising
page to the advertising page and then
also no script tags I can spoof those
and furthermore reducing my my footprint
now sometimes you need special
functionality for instance of course
Google's cognitive capitalism reCAPTCHA
and YouTube and Twitter and so on the
recent versions of you matrix have
allowed you to make it very easy to just
download this recipe that will then
enable a recapture for this very web
session that you're in because unless
you choose to actually persist the
changes by clicking on this lock button
which I've just done without touching a
mouse button that's gonna wait they will
not stay around and when you open the
browser the next time you'll start again
with a clean slide
now at this point let me quickly open up
the Preferences of the browser this is
Firefox chromium or Chrome has has very
similar preferences for privacy and
security and you know it gives you the
possibility now to shoot to block
trackers Firefox light beam is actually
controlling this and I had it turned off
or now have it turned off also
third-party cookies and cookies in
general interestingly you'll note that I
choose not to block third-party cookies
in the browser preferences because it is
a bit of a 1 and 0 decision that I'm
making here third stop resources South
Dakota and that was considered a third
party I don't really want to be blocking
the cookies I wanted much more
fine-grained control over the tracking
behavior that my browser is exposing and
you matrix actually gives that to me the
first column here in that matrix is
about cookies and I'd much more prefer
rather than saying no third-party
cookies whatsoever I'd rather be able to
say look I want cookies from stuff I
actually want cookies from akamai and
then I can able them here or I can say
that Adam Asia I actually want to use
all of them you'll see that the frame
block will override this and so on
play around with a UI a little bit it's
a fantastic resource to use it gives you
a lot of control and I think it's very
intuitive at least to mathematically
thinking minds which is unfortunately
not the vast majority of the of the web
users out there but that's another story
um also sometimes similar to recapture
sometimes you need to use resources that
are being made available on third-party
websites let's have a look at Stack
Overflow when I load Stack Overflow then
it doesn't really work right I mean
that's ok that's a gopher experience for
you right there
so I'm gonna have a quick look yeah I
mean okay that needs to be loaded
stackoverflow static okay so on and so
forth
I can reload the website right there
note how the UI stays in place actually
even forms that you filled in will stay
filled in if you reload it's really nice
I love it but one thing you'll note is
that okay I'm not gonna going going to
demo this right now but one thing about
the website may not work and that's
because it's like overflow loads Ajax
libraries from Google API so calm and
you know even though that's not Google
Analytics com maybe it's still being
used for tracking so but I I kind of
need to enable it now because otherwise
I can't use the website I'm a little bit
in a ditch at this point in time now
wouldn't it be fantastic if I could just
download the Ajax libraries I mean it's
all open source all of these companies
are built on open source anyway it's all
open source if I could just download
that and serve it locally yeah squit
transparent proxy on my laptop okay
let's not go there let's use another
extension that allows me to check this
box here and say I actually would like
to allow something is really wrong with
my mouse button I would really like to
allow script loading from Ajax our
Google API is calm but actually not
contact Google API is calm that
extension is called decentralize with
eyes at the end rather than is e or ize
and the idea of decentralize is that it
includes a couple of standard resources
that can be served locally and that we
which are being updated by this add-on
so I had a previously disabled here
nothing ever happened but if I know now
reload Stack Overflow you can see that
decentralized actually intercepted a
Google hosted library jQuery and served
it from a local resource so now a Stack
Overflow works because I can run Ajax
but Google did not find out about it by
the way if I'm going to be releasing
maybe to the conference mailing list
list of these add-ons that I'm talking
to you about so that you can look at
them one by one after the talk you don't
have to take notes or scramble to take
them down so that's great at this point
in time let me introduce another why did
I have this in here
there was a very good reason why I
wanted you to look at board panda and I
can't remember now so let me just skip
over that and instead talk to you about
cookies because cookies are actually
also useful they're not just used for
tracking they are also used to store
your customizations of a site and maybe
also your login cookies your tokens that
for for OAuth or what have you this
extension which is called cookie
auto-delete gives you again fine-grained
control over the way that your browser
deals with cookies generally in the
Preferences of the browser you can
choose to delete the cookies after the
browser session or honor the lifetime of
the cookie but that is a global setting
what cookie auto-delete allows you to do
is to first of all control this on a per
side basis actually on a per cookie
basis by now that's the latest version
that introduced this and then
furthermore it can enable cookies but
get rid of them right after you stopped
visiting a website so if you look at the
settings then it has this thing called
automatic cleaning and I can send it to
120 seconds or 86,400 or whatever your
preference is again this is about giving
you the power to make your own choices
and then when I stopped visiting stuff
TopCoder than said 120 seconds later
this extension will go through your
browser local storage and delete all the
cookies and all the local storage except
for the ones that you ID listed and this
is actually what the UI that I just
showed is all about
I could whitelist board panda comm and
that would mean that when I restart my
browser the cookies that board panda set
would be available again if I only gray
listed board panda calm then they would
simply stay around until the end of the
browser session so at this point in time
I'm ready to take some questions but I
would like let me let me do one more one
more of these add-ons which is called
multi account containers that's actually
not really an add-on it's actually if
feature that is being built into Firefox
and has been there for a lot of years
who's used multi-account containers that
is the vast minority ok multi-account
containers are basically containers for
tabs or domains tabs actually I think
and the idea is that you'll have a
different set of cookies and local
storage and browsing history and so on
and so forth for individual sites you
can load Facebook in one container and
Twitter in another container and the
browser that they would actually never
be able to find out about each other
sessions because they have completely
separate namespaces you can you can edit
these containers and there is actually
an integration with the cookie
auto-delete UI and you can choose to
keep certain cookies for certain
containers and furthermore
compartmentalize the way that you
interact with the web so I think that
now that I've shown you the most the
four most important of these add-ons and
I have a couple of more to go that are
about minor or less less obvious ways in
which you're being tracked at this point
in time are there any questions is there
anything I can I can answer yes how do
you go with these extensions becoming
stale one of the big problems with the
Mozilla ecosystem in the browser is that
you end up with extensions firstly that
just don't get maintained and when they
have a big changeover like they did
recently a lot of extensions just
stopped working right and secondly the
the whole issue of people selling their
extension to a third party and ending up
with malware in the extension yeah
that's a very good question all the
extensions I've shown so far are life
projects and that are completely free
and open source there are some
that like what was the one called
ghostery rent grocery is one that that
used to do a lot of this work and also
request policy which have been sold and
nobody really knows what happens now
anymore with them so it's part of your
due diligence really to look at this
sort of aspect but that's the same due
diligence you would do with any tool
that you invest some time with and
choose to actually incorporate into your
workflow and I'm part of your due
diligence here because I'm telling you
these are great and the more of you who
jump on board the greater they will be
because they will all actually have
repos on github so it's and they are
very how should I say they are meeting a
big demand at the moment so that the
activity in these repos is actually very
high so I'm confident that they're good
but in ten years we'll have other ones
better ones ai Thank You Martin one of
the things I'm seeing is people have
these API keys and it goes part of the
get and any of these browsers with their
extensions Pratt them that's also a
security hole somebody can start selling
these API keys when they log to their
site and things like that have you
thought of that
yeah API keys I referred to them earlier
as authentication tokens I mean it's
part of the authentication ecosystem
there now they are stored in local
storage and you're a browser and so a
this the cookie auto-delete extension
for instance can take care of local
storage for you as well so you can have
those API keys deleted 120 seconds after
you leave a tab I don't know how they
fit into the matrix UI maybe other it's
possible but that's definitely something
to look at
API keys are only I mean you're you're
touching on an important subject here
I've shown you this sort of like
low-hanging fruits of the footprint that
you're leaving on the web there are a
lot more there's this wonderful website
called browser leaks and basically
browser leaks gives a lot of tools that
you can run to test how much information
trackable information your browser is
leaking
during the the session and it goes as
far as you know exploiting bugs in
JavaScript implementations of particular
browsers that then allow pretty accurate
identification of a person that has
previously been to the site so tracking
you but I won't go into every single one
of these now let's take one more and
then let me do some more extensions and
do more questions at the end yeah I am
I maintain usually a slash at c / hosts
file to block all the sort of the common
offenders do you do that and if so
what's been your experience blogging
thing is that way et Cie hosts is a DNS
type like precursor I mean basically
what you can express there and can only
happen on the level of looking up the
main names and resolving them into IP
addresses
I wouldn't know for instance how many
domains Google owns so I don't know what
to put in there I mean obviously it is a
good resource and especially with what
is it called add away or something on
Android I mean that's one of the only
resources that you have to actually
block tracking across all of the apps
but I think it's it's actually either at
the wrong level so if you wanted to
prevent tracking at the HTTP level you
got to be speaking HTTP and not DNS that
said you matrix does have a way to auto
update assets so a couple of people have
will publish hosts files and so on and
then you matrix puts those into the into
the UI because I didn't go through and
and make every single one of these rows
that have tracking capabilities blue
that was actually provided by some of
these third-party assets okay now let me
continue and give you a couple of more
add-ons
I think the reason why I loaded board
panda was because of the service workers
and because I turned off service workers
earlier on you matrix you didn't
actually get to see this extension here
except he did in action so block service
workers is really easy it just blocks
service workers it actually doesn't
provide a way to whitelist them at the
moment which is kind enough because
sometimes you really need them at the
moment my Twitter experience basically
means that nothing can get pushed to me
all I have to reload to see if somebody
has mentioned me which actually isn't so
bad
think about it it's worse with github
for instance I mean github is lovely in
the sense that I can write a comment on
a patch and then when the author writes
back 30 seconds later I will actually I
will actually be able to have a
discussion right there in almost
real-time that of course is run by a
service worker and by blocking service
workers altogether I'm disabling that
but then again you know the thought of
this convenience versus the idea that a
thread keeps running for hours after I
closed the tab and still operates within
the context of my interaction with that
website it's kind of scary and so I
choose that which I consider a more
safer approach there's also this thing
called tracking in the query strings
right you've all see the scene the UTM
source and UTM whatever it is and ways
by which the companies are trying to
figure out which channel brought you to
their website you can you can leave that
on of course because after all it is
very helpful also to companies to find
out what sort of outreach what sort of
marketing actually is effective but if
you really care more about your privacy
you can turn them off you can using this
extension here which is control called
request control rules you can disable
for instance Google link tracking by
simply ticking this box and block beacon
requests beacons being
little messages that are being sent out
regularly to tracking sites to make sure
that they will find out continuously
what you are up to on the web now there
there's actually it's very much oh shoot
I can't find this no that's the thing
with live demos here in like in the
state of adrenaline and then you're like
oh this was so easy I do it all the time
and now I just can't figure out how to
do it so excuse me have a look the
extension yourself and there's a manual
tada
it allows you to customize all of this
and basically to your liking but I
already find the UI to be very intuitive
and it'll take you a long way towards
protecting your privacy just to install
it and it sort of has privacy and
security by default most of these have
them by default on the settings which I
think goes very much in line with what
serena has said earlier and also is what
you should be doing what's another
extension I have how many minutes do I
have left ten minutes okay let me show
you these two more extensions and then I
think we can call it a day yeah here you
go
current active user agent yeah I'm using
Apple WebKit Chrome which is in Safari
which is definitely not the case I mean
look at this laptop so this is actually
an extension called random UA and I'm
sort of trying to hack on it a little
bit to the point where I'd like to have
the browser send out a different user
agent for every single request just to
make it extremely hard for anyone out
there to correlate my behavior and
because it's not so cool if at some
point in time it's going to be sending
out the fact that I'm using Internet
Explorer 4 so yeah well duck typing is
not something that web developers have
heard of but I've I kind of figured out
that what we can do is actually pretend
that we're using Internet Explorer 425
and then you know chrome 7218 just keep
going up basically because then you get
all the cool features having a modern
browser is the way to go anyway
James I'd be the answer I didn't
understand what you were saying but I
will say yes and let's virus test
pattern I know the virus test pattern
okay
we'll chat yes the question was have you
considered that by generating a unique
user agent string you're giving everyone
the ability to track you even better yes
for that one request that next image
it's gonna have a completely different
one so no okay what's this one there's a
final one here it's called canvas
blocker oh yeah that's one of my
favorites so the web has become a
fantastically interactive resource right
you can do multimedia there's actually
yesterday there was a presentation
though this morning was a presentation
and another mini conf about real-time
audio generation in your browser your
browser is at the same time as it is a
sketching pad it's also a mixer module
and it's a speaker and it's a microphone
and it's I've got a camera and
everything all of these things can be
used to identify you as a matter of fact
this browser leaks website has a module
in there that can with I don't know a
very high level of accuracy identify you
according to the white noise that your
microphone introduces into the browser
stream even though you haven't given a
permission so this is another extension
that I choose to enable which basically
adds some random white noise on top of
that again making it different for every
single request and to make it harder for
those people out there to track because
I value my privacy
I want to value I want to use the web
for the amazing resource that it is but
I'm stepping up the web against the
privacy violating trackers out there and
if they want to keep up tracking me and
making sure that they
can monetize my data they're going to
have to step up their game as well after
I installed all these extensions so
that's all I have time for to show to
you today we do have time for another
five minutes for questions I believe so
let's go for that and thank you very
much for your attention
[Applause]
in my case should I use the private
browsing feature or should I use your
method I think you should use my method
and rather than the private browsing
feature because the private browsing
feature is really a feature that
protects you from your boss it makes
sure that your history file is not being
updated that the bookmarks are not
accessible and all these kind of things
but it is actually not to the best of my
knowledge not something that's outward
facing so even in a private window even
though you are sort of like isolated
from your work for instance while you go
and look at cats right it'll still push
all of these data out there it'll still
reach out to 79 third-party sites while
you're surfing that web site um quite a
number of sites say we detect you using
an ad blocker you know you can't proceed
till you turn it back on is there an
easy way around that to leave them not
tracking it well I I don't want to
propagate the use of ad blockers first
start as I said earlier I mean we do
want to make sure that the independent
media industry has enough money to stay
independent on the other hand it is
annoying that yes like the New York
Times and some other web sites they have
started introducing these windows that
overlay the entire site and say
basically can you turn off your web
you're at tracker there are some really
good examples of how they're doing
things right for instance in Germany a
suit deutsche title they go through
lengths to explain to you who they're
giving the data to that's in part
probably informed by the gdpr
and it I'll actually allow
to make that decision using you matrix
for that one site to actually give
permission to display ads then there are
others that are really bad they
basically say either do this or you
can't come here you could file gdpr
violation claims against them because
according to the gdpr your you must let
me use your site whether I give you my
data or not and otherwise I'm going to
sue you for up to four percent of your
turnover but maybe that's not the right
way to go about it sometimes sometimes
you can go to the dumb editor and simply
select that window and click delete and
then read the website assitive so that
goes line again with Savino said I think
it hurt security and easy ways around it
but in general I mean write a message to
them and say look I'm happy to pay for
you can you please not monetize my data
or feed my data to third parties I think
that's the best answer I have you
mentioned you weren't really a fan of
Danish level tracking in tracking
blocking but what are your thoughts on
using for example a pie hole especially
in the case where you don't have this
kind of control game consoles Smart TVs
smart fridges or whatever you have you
got a V&O option within the device
itself to do any of this so really I
believe your only option is something
like that do you have any sort of
thoughts would you use something like it
well if it's better than nothing then
yeah of course
I didn't want to say that DNS blocking
is bad anything anything that steps up
the game against these privacy abusers
is good right
I just don't convert there are better
tools out there but as you as you said
correctly the gaming console is not
going to let you install your matrix so
put Linux on there and then are you
familiar with the with projects like the
brave browser project and could you
comment on what do you think they're
doing well or not well enough I I'm
familiar with the existence of the brave
browser I've not actually used it to the
point where it can comfortably answer
that question but it's great to see
projects like the brave browser out
there which are really privacy
preserving browsers and I hope that
they're going to grow this sort of fine
grained possibility
maybe even in a way that it's private
and secure by default and then they
figure out really smart ui/ux approaches
to tapping into your preferences
figuring out what you really are
comfortable with because my privacy and
your privacy their aunt Maura
understandings are completely different
right thank you one question I have is
how long does it take you to sort of
browse the web with all of these layers
that you need to sort of manipulate who
actually get to the content because I
feel like the cognitive overload that
I'll have to go through just cleaning
out everything it's just gonna be too
much when I actually need to just get
some work done yeah that's a very valid
question
so I actually come from from no script
and request control a lot of people have
probably used that which we're two
extensions where you had to do the same
thing pretty much for all of the
websites and it was not intuitive and
they had different paradigms of usage
and it was a pain and I ended up
actually not using them anymore in and
I'm just saying temporarily I lie
everything right and so that's not the
goal I find that you matrix is a lot
more intuitive and it does these two
things at the same time and then once
you if you're actually ready to do that
to invest some time at the very
beginning you can benefit from that for
a long time so I work for my web
browsing habits most of the websites I
visit are the same ones over and over
again so having installed these
preferences once gets me the benefits
later but yes in preparation of one of
my other talks that I'm giving later
this week where I wanted to do a lot of
images and so on and so forth yeah I
spend a lot of time
clicking allow this temporarily just in
order for me to be able to load the
images and there's actually an issue
request a feature request for you matrix
of mine in there that basically lets me
assign a key combination to do this does
that answer your question
I have a related question so I also have
plugins that take me forever to actually
end up loading a page sufficiently so I
can use it if my mom wants to install
plugins to protect her browser tracking
you mentioned earlier
but a lot of these you can just install
set-and-forget and they give you a good
level of security can you comment on
what non-technical people can do to
protect them good question thank you Ben
so the e FF even though they have just
partnered with a questionable company
out there and are getting a lot of stuff
about that have a website out there
called Penn optic click which is
currently not loading also have a an
extension out there which is called
privacy badger
and privacy badger and there's another
one that I forget the name off that is
at the at the moment at the top of the
curated list of privacy add-ons in
Firefox and that is very similar
basically take all of this away they say
just enable it and we'll be will then
look at your browsing habits and try to
figure out what what you like and what
you don't like and I think that is a
fantastic application of machine
learning that's probably happening in
the background and that is what I would
install for anybody who doesn't want to
be dealing with matrices and
configuration but for me personally and
probably most of you in the room I do
like to be in control of that matrix
rather than have machine learning decide
what I consider private and what not
alright well on which note I'm going to
have used that opportunity to ask the
last question we are going to lunch but
a big round of applause for that